this 3d printed tracheal implant saved
this baby's life and some cockroaches
have evolved to avoid poison traps that
use sugary bait so yeah
Vsauce Kevin here this is mine
this robot tells you if you have bad
breath
developed by crazy lab Oana Kitakyushu
National College of Technology
the humanoid responds to the smell of
your breath with phrases like it smells
like citrus and it works by using gas
sensors that create a chemical footprint
which can be matched to specific odors
there's also a robot dog that will smell
your feet while these are novel
applications they have more serious ones
for this technology down the road
including using it in medical fields
cosmologists believe they found the
first hard evidence of multiple
universes data from the Planck satellite
of cosmic radiation shows large cold
spots that according to our
understanding of physics shouldn't exist
theoretical physicist dr. mirsini
Houghton believes the anomalies are
caused by other universes pulling on our
universe as it forms during the Big Bang
and while many scientists are skeptical
of other universes these unexplained
features of the map will at least
require new physics to be understood
according to the European Space Agency
tracking point has developed an
interface similar to a fighter jet
display for their precision guided
firearms it not only displays
information like range wind speed and
shot angle but allows the user to lock
onto the target with a desired impact
point critics say that it takes the fair
chase principle away from hunting and
others wonder if this technology should
be in the hands of civilians and they
range in price from 17 to $22,000 newly
discovered mini spider from China
antiquity music has developed the wheel
harp a chamber string orchestra keyboard
allows you to play 61 bowed strings
there are currently four prototypes and
they're crowdfunding the project right
now here's what it sounds like
ceil is a wearable swim monitoring
system that warns parents and lifeguards
if someone is drowning the neckband has
four levels of alert and can be set
depending on the experience of the
swimmer and when in danger it sends a
warning signal or full alarm to the
monitoring hub find a link below for
more Bayer conductive have created
electrically conductive paint it allows
you to apply paints to walls and other
surfaces that enable a kind of liquid
wiring it's non-toxic and can be used
for simple things like turning on lights
or creating interactive art or posters
hot pink slog mobile I visions
technologies is developing a camera only
autonomous driving system that uses just
a few hundred dollars worth of materials
while not as advanced as a self-driving
Google car it uses technology currently
seen in Volvo's that predict and react
to pedestrians and cyclists and they
have plans to introduce more advanced
systems by 2016 finally sonic water is a
cymatics installation visualizing sound
and vibration with the music of KY mad
I'm gonna leave you with a 3d printed
robot that plays pool and as always
thanks for watching